Now in this section, we will explore when to use Unreal Game Sync as your front-end user interface.
So Unreal Game Sync provides a graphical front-end user interface to sync Unreal Engine projects from Perforce
with an option to build those projects with Microsoft's Visual Studio compiler.
It's a skin for Perforce that allows users to implement version control more easily.
Unreal Game Sync, or UGS, is a tool that promotes code and content integration in collaborative development environments.
This enables teammates, distributed over time and distance, to labor on the same projects as it gets updated on the backend.
Basically, Unreal Game Sync can only be used with a custom Unreal Engine build that is stored, maintained, and rebuilt from Perforce through Unreal Game Sync.
Unreal Game Sync users can convert their release version Unreal Engine project to a C++ version Unreal Engine project
and utilize Microsoft Visual Studio to rebuild that engine from Perforce.
When a team is working on a custom Unreal Engine project build,
they're working in an environment where code and content is continuously developed and integrated into that project.
One thing to note is that UGS Binaries Depot Path is a global path.
That pathway is listed here.
So when you set up your own Unreal Game Sync options,
make sure that you follow the path shown here to your project binaries and save the UGS binaries inside your custom Perforce build.
That's it for this section.
Next, we will explore the last pillar of the collaborative production pipeline with collaboration tools.
.